それでは、週刊金融日記 第七百五十一号をお届けします。
今回は、「強力なオープンウエイトエーアイが世界にばら撒かれ、世界でハッキング祭りが始まりましたが、人類の平常運転です」、そしてノーベル賞ウィーク、APEC前の駆け込みでしんせんに行って買い物して美味しい四川中華を食べてきました、さらに既婚者用の出会いアプリは地獄絵図でした、など、内容盛りだくさんでお送りします。
こんにちは、ふじさわかずきです。
最近は広州で真夏にスノーボードをしたりしていたんですが、今回はちょっとご無沙汰だった香港のウエイクサーフィンに行ってきました。
場所は香港の大潭（Tai Tam）です。
この辺は崖に家がたくさん建っていて、僕もそのうち引退してFIREしたら、地下鉄の駅も近くになくてちょっと不便ですけど、この辺の家でも買って、のんびり魚釣りでもしながら、魚釣り＆魚料理のユーチューバーにでもなろうかな、なんて思っていました。
ただ、実際このエリアの家を調べてみたら、中心地よりも高くて、ぼろっちい家でも最低十億円とか、それぐらいの値段なんですよね。
思わずそっと香港のスーモ的なサイトを閉じてしまいました。
ウエイクサーフィンというのは、推進するボートが作る引き波に乗って楽しむもので、なので常に均一な人工の良い波があるサーフィンなんです。
ただ、ふつうのボートではダメなんです。
波を作る専用の設備が必要ですし、ボートに近づき過ぎて転ぶとスクリューに当たったら大事故になりますから、スクリューが下の方についていたりなど、特別な仕様のボートが必要です。
ふつうのボートでやるのは絶対にやめてください。
香港ではコロナ禍のとき、ゼロコロナ政策で、海外に行って帰ってくると本当に二週間缶詰めのような本格的な検疫がありました。
そのせいで、よほどのことがない限り海外に行くことができず、みんな狭い香港の中で遊ぶしかなかったんです。
その時に、意外にも海も山もあって自然豊かな香港でウエイクサーフィンが大ブレイクして、僕も始めました。
料金は休日だと少し高くて、だいたい一時間千三百香港ドル、日本円で約二万六千円くらいですね。
流行していたときはもっと高かったです。
これはボートと、必ずボートの運転手がインストラクターを兼ねているので、その一時間あたりの料金なんです。
それを参加した人数で割るので、三人で二時間やるとだいたい一人一万七千円くらいになります。
でも、コロナ禍も終わって、香港から東南アジアのリゾート地に格安で行けるようになっていますし、となりのしんせんは物価も半額ですし、巨大な屋内スキー場までできています。
そのため、香港のウエイクサーフィン人気は下火になってきたんですよね。
実際僕も今年は一度も行っていなくて、そろそろシーズンも終わるなぁ、ということで今回予約したわけです。
そしたら、コロナ禍のときは予約が入りまくりだった大潭のウエイクサーフィン屋さんも、新しいボートを買ったり、どうやら親子で経営しているんですが、親の方の車がめちゃくちゃカッコいい数千万円はしそうなスポーツカーになっていたりしていました。
その息子さんによくボートに乗せてもらって、いろいろと教えてもらっていたんです。
この息子さん、実は初めて証券口座を開いてエヌビディア株を買ったお兄さんなんです。
素晴らしいタイミングでエヌビディア株を買いましたね！
ところが久しぶりに見たら、毎日稼働してきれいだったボートが、けっこうボロくなっていました。
ボートって、使わずに海に停めたままにしておくと、すぐ悪くなっちゃうんですよね。
それで、そのインストラクターのお兄さん、いまはなんと不動産の営業マンをやっているそうなんです。
こうして予約があったときだけウエイクサーフィンのインストラクターをやる、みたいな感じになっていたので、なんだかしんみりしちゃいました。
やっぱり時代は不動産、なんですね（笑）。
さて、こんしゅうは、エーアイ革命の中心企業であるMicronの決算について分析しました。
決算分析だけでなく、Micronという企業の解説や、エーアイ革命によってメモリの需要がどれだけ伸びていくのか、五倍・六倍のピーイー比がミスプライスなのか、シリコンサイクルの再来を予期しているのか、といったポイントまで、いろいろ盛り込んでいます。
Xサブスク（月三USドル）は、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのXアプリからではなくて、宇宙開発を応援する意味でも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのウェブをブラウザで開いて、そこから直接加入していただけると助かります。
また、メルマガ配信後に、来月のAPECが迫るしんせんのアパレル卸売市場についてもアップデートしていきます！
こんしゅうの内容は「エーアイ革命の主役はジーピーユーではない｜Micron 財務年度2026年 第四四半期（Xサブスク）」、そして「しんせん・南油服装卸売市場の歩き方 2026年」などになっています。
こんしゅうも読者のみなさんから興味深い投稿がいくつも届いています。
見どころをご紹介します。
小学生のこどもにパソコンを買い与える適切なタイミングと、おすすめの機種について教えてください。
メモリー株のミスプライシングはパッシブ運用ばかりになったせいなんでしょうか。
既婚者用出会いアプリの恋愛市場は地獄絵図でした。
それでは、こんしゅうもどうぞよろしくお願いします。
ここからは、「強力なオープンウエイトエーアイが世界中にばら撒かれ、ITシステムが次々とハックされていますが、新たな仕事も次々と生まれている」という話題です。
いつものようにメルマガの原稿を書いていると、Xのタイムラインに「速報、大和証券に不正アクセス」という見出しが流れてきました。
問い合わせ対応を委託している会社のサーバーが破られて、約十一万人分の氏名、メールアドレス、口座番号などが漏えいした可能性があるそうです。
最近、こういった大きなハッキングのニュースが増えていますよね。
ここ一ヶ月ほど、日本ではほぼ毎日のように「不正アクセス」「情報漏えい」「ランサムウェア」という見出しが流れています。
九月ごろから始まった「ハッキング祭り」について、エーアイを使っていろいろ調べてもらいました。
日本だけでも以下のような感じです。
日付は公表日です。
八月十七日、さくらインターネット。
当初は「五百八十三件の不正ログイン」と発表されましたが、二日後には最大約百三十六万アカウントに拡大して、さらに約三年前から侵入されていたことまで判明しました。
九月十一日、デジタル庁のGSS。
VPN機器の既知の脆弱性を突かれて、約二十四万六千件。
九月十五日、ムラウチドットコムでは約七百七十二万件の個人情報が外部に持ち出されたことが確かになっています。
九月十六日、Gyazo。
ユーザー関連データ約二千三百六十二万件、画像のメタデータは約四億九千万件。
九月二十六日、京王グループではランサムウェアによって京王ストアの決済や京王プラザホテル、バスの定期券販売などに障害が起きました。
九月二十八日、タイムズカー（パーク二十四）。
約六百六十万アカウント。
しかも運転免許証などの本人確認書類の画像が約百六十万件。
退会した人の分までデータが残っていて、それも盗まれたんです。
九月二十九日、セイコーマート。
アプリ経由で約五十七万人分の会員情報が閲覧されました。
九月二十九日、ヤマト運輸。
「クロネコ代金後払い」が不正アクセスによってサービス停止。
九月三十日、佐川急便。
約百日分の送り主や届け先の氏名、住所、電話番号が流出した可能性があり、荷物追跡など九つのウェブサービスを停止しました。
十月二日、第一生命。
従業員や退職者あわせて約十二万人分。
十月初旬、ジャパンタイムズ。
不正アクセスを受けて、ランサムウェア集団が犯行声明を発表。
十月五日、焼肉きんぐ。
公式アプリの登録者ほぼ全員、約千七十九万件。
十月五日、大阪公立大学。
ランサムウェアにより約五百台のサーバーが停止し、バックアップの多くも暗号化されてしまって、十月八日まで全授業が休講。
十月五日、大和証券。
委託先経由で約二十二万件。
そのうち個人を特定できるのは約十一万人分。
そして、この原稿を書いているきょう、十月六日だけでも、さらにニュースが流れてきました。
ミスターマックス。
アプリとオンラインストアの会員、最大約百七十四万人分の氏名、メールアドレス、電話番号などが漏えいした可能性があり、アプリとオンラインストアを停止。
GMOリサーチ&エーアイ。
アンケートサイト「infoQ」の会員、最大約九十五万人分の個人情報が流出。
しかもポイント約二百八十七万円分が、勝手にアマゾンギフトコードに交換されていました。
東洋紡エムシー。
従業員のメールアカウントが乗っ取られました。
カーシェア、コンビニ、通販、宅配便、焼肉チェーン、大学、鉄道、生命保険、新聞、国の役所、そして証券会社まで、もはや全業種でハッキング祭りが開催中です。
警察庁によると、脆弱性を探し回る怪しいアクセスは、前年同期より五割も増えています。
まるで、誰かが日本中の家のドアノブを、片っ端からガチャガチャ回して歩いているような状態ですね。
この背景には、強力なエーアイが世界中にばら撒かれていることがあります。
警察庁の「サイバー空間をめぐる脅威の情勢等」も要チェックです。
続いて、「世界トップのハッカーと同じ腕を持つオープンウエイトエーアイ」についてです。
話はことしの四月にさかのぼります。
アンソロピックがMythosというエーアイを発表しました。
このエーアイはソフトウェアの脆弱性を次々と見つけてしまいます。
あまりにも危険なので一般公開されず、マイクロソフトやCrowdStrikeなど一部の企業しか使えませんでした。
それでも提携企業といっしょに、深刻な脆弱性を一万件以上も見つけたそうです。
これには日本の金融庁も震え上がりました。
今年五月には全金融機関に対して、最新のエーアイを悪用した攻撃に備えよ、場合によってはシステムを止めることも考えるように、という異例の要請を出しています。
問題はここからなんです。
アメリカの最先端エーアイに数ヶ月遅れで迫る性能のエーアイが、すでに誰でも無料でダウンロードできるようになっているんですね。
DeepSeek、Kimi、GLM、Qwenといった中国勢のオープンウエイトエーアイも登場しています。
今回は、「週刊金融日記 第七百五十一号」をお届けします。
メインテーマは、強力なオープンウエイトエーアイが世界中にばら撒かれ、サイバー攻撃が活発化していることについてです。
ノーベル賞ウィーク、APEC前の駆け込みで深センに行ってきた話、美味しい四川中華を食べてきた話、既婚者用出会いアプリが悲惨だった話など、さまざまな話題がありますが、ここでは最新のエーアイ事情とサイバーセキュリティの話から始めていきます。
まずは、英国政府のエーアイセキュリティ研究所の評価によると、今やオープンウエイトエーアイは最先端から四〜七か月遅れのところまでキャッチアップしてきているそうなんです。
しかも、付いている安全装置はほとんど役に立たなかったんですね。
たとえば、DeepSeekの最新版はサイバー攻撃の課題をこなすコストが一件あたり約0.28ドルと、米国の最先端エーアイの数十分の一になっています。
あるセキュリティ企業のテストでも、DeepSeekが米国製のいっぱん向けエーアイを抑えて、脆弱性の発見数でトップに立ちました。
[EN]●How Far Behind the Frontier are Leading Open Weight Models on Cyber?[/EN]
[EN]●We burned 11.7bn tokens to find the best cyber AI model[/EN]
つまり、少し前まで一部のハッカー集団しか持っていなかった腕前が、今やタダで世界中にばら撒かれたことになるんです。
そして、一度ばら撒かれてしまったものは、もう二度と元には戻せません。
ここで、「古い穴を探すコストがゼロになった」ことについて考えてみたいと思います。
日本で起きているサイバー事件の手口を振り返ってみると、VPN機器の既知の脆弱性だったり、パッチを当てていない業務ツール、設定ミス、そして委託先のサーバーなど、どれも決して最新の天才的な手口じゃないんですね。
むしろ、昔からある“鍵のかけ忘れ”のような基本的なミスが狙われています。
エーアイランサムウェアを分析した研究者は、エーアイエージェントを使うことで、過去に発見された脆弱性を片っ端から試すコストが事実上ゼロになると警告しています。
だからこそ、放置された古いシステムほど今まで以上に危険になってくるわけです。
今までハッカーたちは、儲かりそうな大企業の中枢を手間をかけて狙っていました。
でも、エーアイの力によって、世界中の鍵のかけ忘れを二十四時間、三百六十五日、タダで探しまわれるようになりました。
これによって、中小企業や委託先、古いシステムもすべて標的範囲に入ってしまったんです。
これだけ多種多様な日本の会社が一斉にやられているのも、決して偶然ではないはずです。
続いて、防御側もオープンウエイトエーアイで武装するしかない、という話に移りたいと思います。
攻撃側がエーアイで武装したなら、防御側もエーアイで武装していかないとバランスが取れません。
具体的には、攻撃者より先にエーアイを使って、自分の穴を見つけて塞いでしまう流れになります。
ところがここにややこしい問題がありまして、米国製のエーアイは安全装置がしっかり付いているため、 Anthropic が六月に発表したMythosと同じ中身に安全装置を強化したFableを例に挙げると、「このシステムの脆弱性を探してほしい」と頼んでも、防御目的なのに断られてしまうケースが多いんです。
最悪の場合、「こいつは怪しいハッカーだ」と判定され、アカウントがバンされることもあります。
本人確認した専門家向けプログラムで制限を緩和される場合も一応あるんですが、手続きがとても面倒です。
しかも、米国政府の政策ひとつでいつでも止まるリスクがあります。
実際、そのFableも発表からわずか三日後に米商務省の輸出規制の影響で一時的に使えなくなったんです。
なので、防御側も自社のサーバーラックで、強力なオープンウエイトエーアイを動かそうという流れになってきます。
会社の機密コードを外部に出さなくて済みますし、外部の判断で止まる心配もありません。
さて、ここから、そういったエーアイラックについての面白い話があります。
エーアイラックというのは、実はメモリの塊なんです。
自前でエーアイを動かすためには、何が必要なのか。
例えばDeepSeekの最新版だと、パラメータは一兆六千億もあります。
これだけ大規模なモデルを動かすには、最新のジーピーユーを八基も積んだサーバーが一台か二台必要になります。
そのジーピーユーに載せる高速メモリ、つまりエイチビーエムだけで二〜五テラバイト、サーバー本体のメモリもさらに数テラバイト必要になります。
そして、そのメモリが今、とんでもなく高騰しているんですね。
サーバー用ディーラムの契約価格は、ことしの一月から三月だけで九割以上も値上がりしました。
Dellの注文画面では、六十四ギガバイトのメモリ一枚が九千九百ドルを超えていて、一部の容量については「提供終了」と表示されています。
エイチビーエムに関しては、大手三社とも、ことし分の生産をほとんどすべて売り切っています。
こうしたローカルエルエルエムを満足に動かせるエーアイラック一セット分のメモリ代だけで、日本円で二千万円くらいになります。
しかも、どう考えても、この需要は今後さらに増え続けるしかありません。
もちろん、この需要の中心はクラウド大手の巨大なエーアイ投資です。
防御用のエーアイラックの需要は、その上乗せ分にすぎません。
ただ、すでに供給がギリギリの市場では、ちょっとした上乗せでも価格へ大きく影響します。
メモリをはじめとしたエーアイ半導体には、また新しい追い風が吹き始めているわけです。
僕はこのメルマガで何度も書いてきましたが、世の中は、エーアイデータセンター向けの莫大なメモリ需要を一時的なものとしてしか見ていなくて、こうして次々に生まれる新しいメモリ需要はゼロに近いと考えがちです。
でも実際には、どんどんメモリが必要になっていくばかりなんですね。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十九号 メモリ半導体株（Micron、SK hynix、Samsung、Kioxia）の低PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか 需要編』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十号 メモリ半導体株（Micron、SK hynix、Samsung、Kioxia）の低PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか 供給編』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十三号 メモリ半導体の需要と供給について分かっていることを整理しま』
続いては、新しい仕事が次々と生まれている現状についてお話しします。
エーアイを活用して、攻撃者より先に自社システムをテストする「自律型ペネトレーションテスト」という新しい分野では、Horizon3.aiが七千社以上の顧客を持ち、八月には二億五千万ドルを調達しました。
同業のXBOWは評価額が十億ドルを超えるユニコーン企業になっています。
エーアイエージェント自体を乗っ取りから守るZenityのような会社も、次々と大きな資金を集めています。
日本でもGMO Flatt Securityが、エーアイを使って脆弱性を見つけ自動で直すサービスを展開しています。
株式市場も正直ですね。
CrowdStrikeやPalo Alto Networksの株価は、ことしに入ってほぼ二倍になりました。
[EN]●CrowdStrike Holdings, Inc. (CRWD)[/EN]
[EN]●Palo Alto Networks, Inc. (PANW)[/EN]
しかし、本当に足りないのは「穴を見つける人」ではなく「穴を直す人」なんです。
アンソロピック自身も、脆弱性自体は大量に見つかるものの修正作業がまったく追いつかないと漏らしています。
エーアイが発見した大量の穴を、どの順番でどう塞いで、業務を止めずにどうやってシステムを入れ替えていくのか。
こうした判断と実行ができる人には、これからますます需要が集まっていくでしょう。
エーアイによってITエンジニアの仕事が消えると予測されていましたが、実際はシステムの脆弱性を直すITエンジニアが猛烈に不足している状況なんですね。
それに加えて、エーアイラックを設計して組み立てる人、データセンターの電力や冷却を担う人、メモリ工場で働く人、エーアイの暴走を監視する人も不可欠です。
攻撃と防御の軍拡競争が続く限り、こうした仕事はなくなりません。
むしろ攻撃側が強くなればなるほど、防御側の予算はどんどん膨らんでいきます。
最後に、歴史は繰り返すという話です。
エーアイの話題になると必ず「仕事がなくなる」という悲観論が出てきます。
たしかになくなる仕事もあるでしょう。
でも、人類の歴史を振り返ってみると、技術革新はいつも仕事を奪うと同時に、それ以上の数の新しい仕事を生み出してきたんですね。
十九世紀初頭のイギリスでは、仕事を奪われることを恐れた織物職人たちが工場の機械を壊してまわった、いわゆるラッダイト運動がありました。
しかし、機械化によって布の値段が劇的に下がると、誰もが複数の服を持てるようになり、結果的に繊維産業で働く人数は爆発的に増えたのです。
自動車が登場したとき、馬車の御者や馬の世話係は仕事を失いましたが、その代わり自動車工場の工員や整備士、タクシーやトラックの運転手、ガソリンスタンド、自動車保険、ロードサイドのレストランなど、まったく新しい仕事がたくさん生まれました。
ATMが普及した当時、銀行の窓口係は消えると思われていました。
でも実際、アメリカでは窓口係の人数がむしろ増えたんですね。
支店が増えたことで窓口係は、お金を数える係からお客さんに金融商品を提案する営業係にシフトしたわけです。
表計算ソフトが登場しても会計の仕事は消えず、むしろ金融アナリストという新しい仕事が爆発的に増えました。
今回も同じことが起きています。
エーアイがハッカーを強くし、ITシステムの多くが次々と丸裸になっています。
でもその裏で、エーアイで守る人、エーアイが発見した穴を塞ぐ人、エーアイを動かすラックを作る人、増え続けるメモリを作る人など、数年前まで存在しなかった新しい仕事がどんどん生まれているんです。
歴史は繰り返します。
今回も同じことが起きているのは間違いありません。
ただし、ひとつだけ付け加えておきたいのが、仕事を失う人と新しい仕事に就く人が必ずしも同じ人とは限らないこと。
たとえば馬車の御者が、そのまま自動車の整備士になれたわけではない、ということなんです。
タイトルは「週刊金融日記 第七百五十一号 強力なオープンウエイトエーアイが世界にばら撒かれて、世界でハッキング祭りが始まりましたが、人類の平常運転です。
ノーベル賞ウィーク、エイペック前の駆け込みでしんせんに行って買い物して美味しい四川中華を食べてきました。
既婚者用出会いアプリは地獄絵図でした。
他、夜間飛行 パート三分の五」です。
新しい波に乗れる人というのは、変化を面白がって、新しい道具をいち早く使いこなすことができる人なんです。
そして、ゴールドラッシュの時代にいちばん確実にもうけたのは、実は金（きん）を掘った人じゃなくて、つるはしやシャベルを売った人だったんですよね。
じゃあ、今回のエーアイ軍拡競争での「つるはし」と「シャベル」は何なのでしょうか。
これはもう言うまでもなく、メモリをはじめとするエーアイ半導体なんです。
「週刊金融日記 第七百四十四号」では、「こんしゅうもキオクシア株について語ろうか、Sandiskが二千三十年まで粗利益率八十パーセントが続くと発表」という話もしましたね。
ここからはこんしゅうのマーケットについてです。
二千二十六年九月二十五日から十月二日までの一週間のパフォーマンスは次のとおりです。
[EN]TOPIX:       4091.00, -0.9% (1w), +19.4% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225:  68309.46, +2.9% (1w), +35.7% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:      7722.72, -0.3% (1w), +12.8% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:      157.93, +0.5% (1w),  +1.0% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:      177.63, -0.8% (1w),  -3.3% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut):  91.11, -1.4% (1w), +58.7% (YTD)[/EN]
メモリ不足の長期化が続いているにもかかわらず、マイクロンの株価は動かず、アメリカの雇用が弱かったこともあって利上げ観測は後退しました。
そして、こんしゅうはノーベル賞ウィークにもなっています。
せんしゅう、九月二十五日から十月二日までのかぶしきしじょうは、指数以上にエーアイ関連株への資金集中がはっきりと見られた一週間でした。
TOPIXは週間で0.9パーセント安、S&P500も0.3パーセント安だった一方で、値がさ半導体株に引っ張られて日経平均は2.9パーセントも上昇しました。
日本ではアドバンテストがプラス13.6パーセント、東京エレクトロンがプラス10.8パーセント、TDKがプラス8.1パーセントと大きく上がりました。
アメリカでもASMLがプラス7.1パーセント、TSMCがプラス4.9パーセント、エヌビディアがプラス3.9パーセントとエーアイ半導体関連の主力株は堅調だったんです。
いっぽうで、好決算だったマイクロンはほぼ横ばいでした。
エーアイ関連に資金が集まっている相場が続いています。
ドル円は157円台後半にちょっと円安が進み、WTI原油先物は中東からの供給回復やG7による一億バレルの備蓄協調放出を受けて、週間で1.4パーセント下がって91ドル台となりました。
こんかいいちばん注目だったマイクロンの決算は、だいたい予想通り文句なしに強かったです。
第四四半期の売上高は前年同期比で約4.8倍の五百四十二億ドル、調整後の粗利益率は驚異の87パーセント、イーピーエスは三十三ドル四十二セントとなりました。
次の四半期についても、売上高六百十五億ドル、イーピーエス三十八ドル十五セントと、しじょう予想を大幅に上回るガイダンスが出ました。
さらに経営陣は、メモリとストレージの需給は二千二十七年、二千二十八年には二千二十六年よりもっと逼迫するとして、需給がいつバランスに戻るか「まだ見えていません」と話しています。
長期供給契約は十六件から二十六件に増えて、その他の顧客コミットメントも合わせると、二千二十七年度の生産量の七十五パーセント以上がもう約束された形です。
でも株価がほとんど上がらなかったのは、業績が悪かったからではなくて、年初から数倍に上がった株価に対してしじょうの期待が極端に高まっているからでしょう。
ぼく自身のエーアイと半導体、とくにメモリ株に対する強気の見方はまったく変わりません。
それどころか「メモリ不足が早く終わるかもしれない」という弱気シナリオの方が、今回の決算でさらに後退したと感じたくらいです。
マクロ経済でも、週末のアメリカの雇用統計が大きな材料になりました。
九月の非農業部門雇用者数はしじょう予想では九万人増だったのに、実際はわずか二万九千人増にとどまり、七月と八月分も合計六万人下方修正されています。
失業率も4.2パーセントに上がり、賃金上昇率も前年比3.0パーセントまでゆるやかになりました。
八月の個人消費支出価格指数も予想より低くて、九月に三年ぶりの利上げに踏み切ったエフアールビーが十月に追加で利上げするという観測も大きく後退しています。
金曜日にはこうした材料を好感してアメリカ株が上がったものの、それでも一週間のS&P500は小幅な下げで終わりました。
景気後退を心配するほど悪くはないけれど、エフアールビーが利上げを急ぐほど強くもない、かぶしきしじょうにとって都合のいい内容だったと言えます。
そして、こんしゅうはノーベル賞ウィークでもあります。
五日の生理学・医学賞を皮切りに、六日に物理学賞、七日に化学賞、八日に文学賞、九日に平和賞と発表が続き、経済学賞は翌週の十二日になります。
日本株では八日にファーストリテイリングとセブン＆アイ、九日に安川電機の決算にも注目が必要です。
ファーストリテイリングは円安や原材料・人件費上昇の中でも海外ユニクロの成長が続くかどうか、セブン＆アイは構造改革の進み具合、安川電機は中国を中心にしたファクトリーオートメーションやロボットの需要動向を見定める上で重要になってきます。
そして、G7が石油備蓄一億バレルの協調放出を発表したのは、トランプ氏がアメリカの原油輸出禁止をちらつかせた直後の話です。
マイクロンは売上高予想をしじょう予想を上回る水準で出して、エーアイ需要による受注拡大も出てきています。
「エーアイ革命の主役はジーピーユーではない」というMicron二千二十六年度第四四半期の内容も、Xサブスクで取り上げました。
アメリカ九月雇用者数が二万九千人増と伸びが鈍り、失業率は4.2パーセント、利上げ観測も後退したという流れです。
[EN]●Nobel Prize Announcements 5?12 October 2026[/EN]
Xサブスク（三ドル毎月）なら、主要企業の決算分析やエーアイバブルの現在位置について、ぼくとエーアイによる対談記事が読めます。
購読希望される方は、アップルにピンハネされるiPhoneアプリ経由じゃなくて、スマホやパソコンのブラウザでXのサイトを直接開いて、そこでサブスクリプション登録をしてください。
そのついでに、イーロン・マスクの宇宙開発も応援してもらえたらうれしいです。
ここで、こんしゅうのスケジュールです。
十月五日月曜日には、アメリカの九月ISM非製造業景況指数の発表、そしてノーベル生理学・医学賞の発表があります。
十月六日火曜日は、日本銀行の植田総裁の講演、日本の十年国債入札、アメリカ八月の貿易収支、アメリカ三年国債入札、そしてノーベル物理学賞の発表です。
十月七日水曜日は、日本の八月毎月勤労統計調査、日本八月景気動向指数、アメリカ連邦公開市場委員会（FOMC）の議事要旨、公表、アメリカ十年国債入札、そしてノーベル化学賞の発表があります。
十月八日木曜日には、日本八月国際収支、日本九月景気ウォッチャー調査、日本三十年国債入札、アメリカ三十年国債入札、ノーベル文学賞の発表です。
そしてこの日はファーストリテイリングやセブン＆アイなど決算発表もあります。
十月九日金曜日は、日本八月家計調査、日本九月の工作機械受注、アメリカ十月のミシガン大学しょうひ者態度指数、ノーベル平和賞の発表、安川電機やビックカメラなどの決算も控えています。
十月十日土曜日と、十一日日曜日には、とくに大きな経済イベントは予定されていません。
続いて、「ブログではいえないお店」です。
エイペック前の駆け込みで、しんせんに行って買い物して美味しい四川中華を食べてきた話をします。
らいげつの十一月十八日、十九日にしんせんでエイペック（アジア太平洋経済協力会議）首脳会議が開かれるのですが、このエイペックというのは日本やアメリカ、中国など、環太平洋の二十一の国や地域が参加する、地域経済の統合や貿易自由化について話し合う超ビッグイベントなんですよね。
今回は中国が議長国を務めるわけですが、これは2014年の北京いらいのことで、十二年ぶりです。
その晴れの舞台に選ばれたのが、ハイテク産業が集積する「中国のシリコンバレー」とも呼ばれるしんせんなんです。
しゅうきんぺい政権としては、香港やマカオを巻き込んだグレーターベイエリア（大湾区）の発展ぶりや技術力の高さを世界中にアピールしたいところですよね。
中国でこうした国家級の国際会議が開かれるとなると、街がきれいになったりするのは素晴らしいんですが、地方政府の役人が気を利かせて、外国の要人や海外メディアがたくさん来る前に、世界に見せるには都合が悪いものやグレーゾーンな経済活動を一斉に締め出しかねません。
そこでぼくが気にしているのが、しんせんが誇る巨大アパレル問屋街「南油服装卸売市場」なんです。
南油といえばヨーロッパの高級メゾンの工場横流し品や、精巧な模造品、ノーブランドの高級仕立て服などが怪しく動く、ファッション好きにはたまらないワンダーランドなんですよ。
でも、エイペックで要人がたくさん来るとなれば、しんせんの役人がしゅうきんぺい総書記に恥をかかせまいと忖度して、そういうお店を一斉に片付けてしまう恐れもあるわけです。
そんなわけで、「いまのうちにたくさん買い込んでおこう！
」と思って、しんせんに行ってきたというわけです。
しんせん・南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方、二千二十六年バージョンです。
香港からしんせんへ行くルートはいろいろあるんですが、ぼくは自宅近くから高速バスが出ているので「香港中旅」のCTG BUSを使って深?湾口岸（「口岸」というのは中国語で国境・ボーダーのことです）まで行くのがいちばん便利です。
片道六十五香港ドル、だいたい千三百円くらいで手頃ですし、サクッと行けます。
ぼくはもう慣れているので問題ないですが、チケットの買い方や乗り場の案内など、いまだに分かりにくいところが多いですね。
グレーターベイエリア（大湾区）の発展を世界にアピールしたいなら、こういうところこそ、広東語ができない外国人や観光客にももっと分かりやすく改善してほしいものです。
CTG BUSの利用についてもお話しすると、深?湾口岸のしんせん側には大きなDiDi乗り場があります。
Uberなどライドシェアサービスって、不慣れな場所では自分のいる場所を指定するのがけっこう難しかったりするんですが、深?湾口岸ならどこで呼んでもこの大きな乗り場が指定されるので、ピッと操作すればいいだけなんです。
そして、「週刊金融日記 第七百二十五号」では「ジーディーピー三百五十兆円もある粤港澳大湾区（グレーターベイエリア）は観光地としてもとてつもないです」とも触れました。
この日は、夕方に香港人の知人と南油服装卸売市場で合流する予定だったんです。
僕は、一人でお昼に行って、たっぷり買い物をしようと思っていたんですが、もたもたしていたら、結局僕が着いたのも夕方になってしまって、大急ぎで買い物をすることになりました。
だいたい、ズボンやシャツは一着二百元から三百元、ジャケットなんかだと五百元から六百元ぐらいが相場ですね。
ちゃんと素材や縫製なんかが分かっていると、本当にいいもの、つまり正規のブランドとして売ればズボンやシャツが十万円ぐらい、ジャケットなんかは四十万円以上するようなものが、この値段で買えるんです。
でも、そこは文字通り「そうは問屋が卸さない」わけで、適当に急いでパッパと買っていると、まあ値段相応のものを掴むことになるんですよね。
その辺のガチャ要素も含めて面白いんですけど。
このあたりの南油服装卸売市場の詳しい話は、Xサブスクの方に書いてアップします。
何とかこんやかあしたぐらいには書きますが、結論から言うと、日本人の女性なら百十一号棟に行くといいですし、男性なら百三号棟に行くのがいいですね。
そして、買い物のあとは、香港人の知人がだいでんぴん（Dianping）で見つけた四川中華のお店に行きました。
お店の名前は、「灯花・川小館」です。
深セン市南山区粵海街道高新南一道十三号にあるお店です。
お店の名前の「灯花」は、中国語で「灯りの花」つまり「ほのお」を意味していて、四川料理の辛さと温かさを感じさせるネーミングになっています。
このお店は、だいでんぴんで四・八点（五点満点）という高得点を取っています。
深セン市南山区の科技園、いわゆるハイテクパークのエリアにあります。
入口からしてとても雰囲気が良くて、これは当たりだと確信しました。
メニューもタブレットで見やすく、適当に頼みました。
青島ビールもあって良かったです。
あと、中国のレストランって、輸入ワインにはかんぜいがかかっているのか、コスパが良くないことが多いんですが、その代わりほとんどのお店で無料で持ち込みできます。
ただ、ここは南アフリカ産のワインがリーズナブルでした。
まあ、写真を見てください、って感じですね。
エビの前菜料理が手が込んでいて美味しかったです。
南アフリカは中国と関係が良いから、関税などで優遇されているのかな、南アフリカのワインがリーズナブルでした。
カエルの素揚げ的なやつと赤唐辛子がどっさり出てきたりして、青い唐辛子の方はチキンだったと思います。
四川料理では、こういう赤い唐辛子は基本的に香りづけに使うものなので、残します。
ちょっともったいないですが。
麻婆豆腐もめちゃくちゃ美味しかったし、唐辛子が好きな人には四川料理は最高ですね。
水煮魚（シュイジーユー）みたいな、真っ赤な激辛スープで、魚ではなく牛の胃袋（せんまい）やモツがどっさり入っている料理があったんですが、これは四川名物の『毛血旺（マオシュエワン）』ですね。
コリコリした牛の胃袋に麻辣スープと油が絡んで、冷たいビールや白ワインと一緒に食べると本当に最高です。
こんなに美味しい四川料理を食べて、ワインも飲んで、一人一万円ぐらいでしたね。
ちょっと頼みすぎて、炭水化物系は頼まなかったのにお腹がパンパンだったので、ワイン持ち込んで、ご飯とかも頼めば一人四千円くらいで済むと思います。
この前、広州に行った時に気づいたんですけど、しんせんは香港の半額とか三分の一くらいの物価なんですが、それでも中国本土の中ではかなり物価が高いんですよね。
広州はさらにしんせんよりだいぶ安いです。
ここからは、後世に残す金融日記レストランリストについてです。
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.1
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.2
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.3
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.4
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.5
それから、金融日記レストランリストNo.6として、飲食店が少ないと言われる品川駅周辺の美味しいお店についてもリストアップしています。
続いて、ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談のコーナーです。
「小学生のこどもにパソコンを買い与える適切な時期と機種について教えてください」というご相談です。
いつも楽しく拝読しています、なんどかご相談させていただいている外科医です。
今回はこどもの教育についてご相談させてください。
小学三年生のこどもがいるのですが、いつから、どのようなパソコンを買い与えるべきか悩んでいます。
学校からはジーガスクール構想でアイパッドが一人一台配布されていて、授業や宿題ではそれを使っています。
ただ、宿題で使う程度で、自由に何かを調べたりできるものではなさそうです。
これからの時代、エーアイやプログラミングに早くから触れさせることには大きな意味があると思っています。
こどもにとって、パソコンは「使えて当たり前」の道具になるはずです。
いっぽうで、自分専用の端末を与えると、YouTubeやゲームに時間を吸い取られるだけになるのではないか、という心配もあります。
具体的には、以下の点で迷っています。
小学生のうちに自分専用のパソコンを与えるべきか、もう少し待つべきか。
機種はMac、Windows、Chromebookなどのうち何が良いか。
買い与える時期やその機種について、ご教示いただけますと幸いです。
よろしくお願いいたします。
ふじさわかずきの回答です。
外科医の方であれば、こどもに中学受験をさせるメリットは大きいです。
というのも、国公立医学部は、共通テストが重要なので、小学生から国語・算数・理科・社会と幅広いトピックを勉強すると、だいぶ有利になるからです。
中学受験の経験は、全科目の総合点が重要になる東大や国公立医学部の受験には、ある程度は有効です。
少なくとも、それ以外の英語のウエイトが大きいほかの入試に比べれば、はるかに有効でしょう。
逆に、東大と、六教科八科目の共通テストの点数が重要な国公立医学部以外であれば、教育理論的には、結局、英語と数学の二科目でほとんど決まるので、小学生のうちから英語も勉強していたほうが有利、という考え方もあります。
『コスパで考える学歴攻略法』という本もありますが、こう考えると、こどもの進路としては、国公立医学部受験が第一選択肢の教育指針となるでしょうから、そのためには、小学四年生、正確には三年生の二月から中学受験の塾に入れることになります。
そうなると、パソコンどころではありませんし、それ以前にパソコンを持たせても、こどもにとってリテラシーが足りず、何の役にも立ちません。
むしろ、有害なインターネットの情報にさらされて、良いことは何もありません。
つまり、小学生のこどもにはパソコンは与えない、というのが答えになります。
続いて、メモリー株のミスプライシングはパッシブ運用ばかりになったせいでは、という話に移ります。
ライフハック研究家の方からのご質問です。
所長が最近主張している、メモリー株のミスプライシング説に興味があり、私も自分でメモリー株のピーイーアールと非メモリー半導体株のピーイーアールを比較したりして納得したので、ラウンドヒルメモリーイーティーエフ、通称ディーラムを買ったのですけれども、ミスプライシングが起きている理由を考えてみました。
現在、世界の株式の半分がインデックスファンドでパッシブ運用されています。
パッシブ運用というのは、要するに、他人の判断に相乗りするということです。
これまで株式は、散々アクティブ運用されてきましたが、市場平均に勝てた人やファンドがいませんでした。
そのため、現状はパッシブ運用が支配的になったのですが、あまりにもパッシブ運用ばかりになったために、自分で株式価値を計算する人がいなくなってしまったんじゃないかと思っています。
ふじさわかずきの回答です。
そんな難しい話ではなく、いまのところは、ディーラムでもナンドフラッシュでも、メモリ半導体企業の粗利率、いわゆるグロスマージンは九割近く、営業利益率、つまりオペレーティングマージンも八割超えなんですよね。
でも、そんなのが長く続くわけないだろう！
と、だいたいの市場参加者が思っているので、二千二十七年とか二千二十八年の予想イーピーエスに基づくピーイー比で見ると、四倍とか五倍とか六倍台とか、異常な割安になっているんです。
Micronの決算では、予想通り、あるいは予想を上回る素晴らしい業績が発表されました。
それに対して、僕なんかは、この利益率が続く可能性もそれなりにあるだろうし、これが恒常化したら、株価はいまの四倍とか五倍とかそれ以上になりますし、もうほぼ契約で固まっている二千二十八年くらいの業績にしても、市場は過小評価しているだろうと。
そして、二千二十九年、二千三十年ごろには、僕たちが詳細に分析したように、いま計画中の工場が稼働し始めて、年間ビットきょうきゅうは、さすがにいまの二倍ぐらいまで増産されるんですが、そのころに粗利率が半分になっていても、量も二倍売れるなら、いまと利益はそう変わらないだろう、と考えています。
だから、マーケットは悲観的すぎるんじゃないかと思っていて、きたい値で見れば、メモリ半導体株への投資は素晴らしいと感じているわけです。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十二号 エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株価二十一万円（分割後七万円）超えます』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十三号 メモリ半導体の需要と供給について分かっていることを整理しま』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十四号 こんしゅうもキオクシア株について語ろうか』
それに、パッシブ投資の隆盛がどう市場の効率性を低下させるかについての議論は、もうファイナンス研究において超重要なテーマであって、医学で言えばがんの治療法レベルのビッグテーマです。
だから、そう簡単に論じられるものじゃないし、簡単な答えもないんです。
ただ、基本的にパッシブ投資の比率が上がるというのは、ハイパースケーラーや、こうして時...
価総額が非常に大きくなったメモリー半導体企業への自動的な買いがたくさん入るので、むしろこれはプラスなんじゃないかなと思います。
さて、ここからは既婚者用出会いアプリの恋愛しじょうが地獄絵図だったという話題についてお話しします。
こんにちは、牧場主です。
先日は、出戻りオジの私を温かく迎えてくださり、本当にありがとうございました。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十五号 結婚して週刊金融日記を卒業しましたが８年ぶりに帰ってきました』ということで、初心を思い出してメルマガのバックナンバーを読み直し、筋トレにも励み、服装も整えました。
そしてついに！
まずはイージーウィン・ファーストですが、手頃な女性にゴールを決めてきました。
これは本当に嬉しかったです。
ですが、私は今満身創痍なんです。
もともとストリートナンパの成功率が低かったので、再挑戦にあたってはマッチングアプリを主戦場に選んでみたのですが、そこは魑魅魍魎と最新テクノロジーが融合した、とんでもない世界でした。
きょうは、出戻りオジの悪戦苦闘ぶりと、今現在のマッチングアプリ界隈についてご報告したくてメールしました。
まず、既婚者用マッチングアプリの大手には次の三つがあります。
ヒールメイト、カドル、そして既婚者クラブです。
ヒールメイトは、一対一で不倫するという真面目（というか、ある意味真剣）な出会いを探す人が多くて、カドルはカジュアルに会いたい人が多め、既婚者クラブはその中間ぐらいのユーザー層になっています。
今回は、上位二社であるヒールメイトとカドルを利用し、さらに途中からはマッチングアプリ界の王者であるTinderも併用してみました。
まず驚いたのが料金の高さでした。
ヒールメイトのスタンダード単月プランは九千八百円、カドルのスタンダード単月プランはなんと一万四千九百八十円です。
そして次に、マッチングアプリの難易度がものすごく上がっていることに絶望しました。
こちらとしては、昔のようにいい思いをしたくて、当然のように二十代から三十代前半の女性を対象に設定します。
でも、面白いくらいに全然マッチしません。
そこでやむをえず、対象を四十代前半まで広げたんですが、それでもマッチしないんです。
自分よりけっこう年上の女性からはいいねが届くものの、同年代以下の女性からはほとんど相手にされません。
この辺りで、あることに気がつきました。
女子のみなさんのプロフィールにちょくちょく書かれている「年下が好み」「背が高い人が好き」という文言です。
さすがに「イケメンがいい」とは露骨に書く人はいませんが、どうせ顔がよければ簡単にいいねをするに決まっています。
ぼかし写真のプロフィールでマッチして、ぼかしなし写真を交換したらサッと消えてしまう、なんてこともよくありました。
既婚者用マッチングアプリは、容赦ないルッキズムの戦場でした。
お金を持っているかどうかや、いい仕事をしているかどうかには全然興味がないみたいです。
浮気相手を選ぶ基準は、グッドジーンズ、つまり遺伝子的な価値だけ。
なるほど、恋愛工学の観点から言えば当然の真理なんでしょう。
かつては結婚適齢期の女性とモテループに入れていた私ですが、純粋にグッドジーンズだけで勝負しなければいけない既婚者恋愛しじょうは、本当に過酷な競争で、無残に振られ続けて私の自尊心はズタボロになり、心が折れかけました。
困り果てた挙句、世の中の情報商材に手を出したり、クローズドなグループチャットにも潜入してみたりしました。
そこで見たのは、さらに驚くべきカオスな世界でした。
プロフィール写真をどこからか拾ってきて使うのは当たり前で、自分の写真も生成エーアイで縦横無尽に加工したり、本格的な人はプロのカメラマンに撮影を頼んだりしていました。
そして、一言目のメッセージやアポに持っていくまでのプロトコルなど、マーケティング理論を応用した手法がしっかり確立されています。
このメルマガを読んでいた時代はまだ出会い系のテクニックをそこまで追いかけていなかったので、それがどこまで突き抜けているのかは分かりませんが、今やマッチングアプリのテクニックは非常に洗練されていると言って間違いないと思います。
とはいえ、その基礎は恋愛工学ですでに研究され尽くされていた内容でした。
実際にグループチャットの中でも、恋愛工学の用語がバンバン飛び交っていました。
最先端のマッチングアプリのテクノロジーに触れて分かったのは、気がつけば恋愛工学が一般層にも広まり、日常の当たり前の出会いにも応用されているということです。
ただ、世間に出回っている情報商材には理念がありません。
恋愛工学には「女性を幸せにする」という理念（少なくとも建前上のもの）があるんですよね。
やっぱりそれは忘れたくないなと思いながら、私はきょうもマッチングアプリをぶん回し続けています。
結果的に、基本にして最強の戦略、つまりアービトラージ戦略がうまく当たって、ついに出会えた蜜壺はTinderで出会った三十代のシングルマザーのものでした。
私はただ心のきれいな女性とこっそりしっぽり過ごしたいだけなのに、飛び込んだ先は本当に地獄絵図だった、というお話でした。
続いて、ふじさわかずきさんの回答です。
時代が変わっても、恋愛の基本は変わらないですね。
そもそも出会い系アプリって、写真・年齢・一行肩書き（卒業大学や勤務先）の三つで勝負する場であって、四十代以上の男性が良い思いをできるところではないんですよね。
もちろん、とにかくアポを取り付けるために、それらを偽るというのは広く行われていますが、出会い系アプリを利用していて、フェイクに釣られるぐらいの女性とそうやって出会っても、社会的地位のある四十代以上の男性がそういう女性とうまくやったところで、何かメリットがあるのかと考えると、正直そこまでメリットはないのが本音じゃないでしょうか。
『週刊金融日記 第二百二十三号 フェイスブック連動型出会い系アプリで無双する方法』
『週刊金融日記 第二百六十六号 まだ出会い系アプリで消耗してるの？
インスタグラム編』
いっぽうで、様々なサービスがインターネットに移行する時代を経て、個人売春がパパ活として再発明されて、昔ながらのキャバクラやデートクラブのようなものがネットに移って大衆化し、ちょっとお金を持った中高年男性と、そこら辺の女子大生がカジュアルにつながるようにもなりました。
昔なら、そういったお店などに所属しないとできなかったのが、今はそこらの女子大生がスマホでポチポチやるだけでよくなり、ハードルが極端に下がり、半分プロ化したとも言えるかもしれません。
『週刊金融日記 第三百五十五号 諭吉三人でＳクラスを簡単ゲットできるパパ活しじょうの実態』
『週刊金融日記 第三百五十七号 パパ活がきっかけでモテスパイラルに乗り覇王色の覇気をまとった話』
『週刊金融日記 第三百六十四号 パパ活面接から契約までの流れテンプレ公開』
『週刊金融日記 第五百七十四号 フィリピンのゴーゴー嬢と日本のパパ活女子大生が同じくらいという話』
ということで、写真・年齢・一行肩書き（卒業大学や勤務先）で九割が決まるネット恋愛しじょうでは、四十代以上の男性は当然としてエッジを持てませんし、パパ活しじょうはそれはそれで、風俗や愛人業がネットに移っただけとも言えますし、ちゃんと恋愛したいなら、昔ながらのストリートや立ち飲みバー、あるいは趣味の集まりみたいな所で、立ち振る舞いだったり、人間的・金銭的な余裕などで勝負するのが良いんじゃないかなと思います。
『週刊金融日記 第三百六十六号 ストナンが最強の趣味である』
ここで、恋愛工学の重要バックナンバーもチェックしてみてください。
あと、最近思うのは、女性の性的な魅力が二十代から三十代半ばぐらいまでが一番高いと考えると、少子高齢化社会って、構造的に蜜壺不足になるんですよね。
だって、ボリュームゾーンである四十代や五十代の小金を持った男性も、そこで争うことになるわけじゃないですか。
この辺は、すでに2013年に論文が出ています。
「人口ピラミッドと若い女のプレミアム」2013年二月八日ですね。
そう考えると、日本、それも東京という恋愛しじょう自体が、すでに成長余地が限られる、しんどい市場なんだという見方もあります。
逆に、ピラミッド型で若い女性が余っていて、しかもお金に困っているような東南アジアや南米、アフリカの新興恋愛しじょうで頑張るほうが圧倒的に有利なんですよね。
ちなみに、スマホ一つで外国の株には投資できますが、恋愛市場は実際に自分が行かないといけないんで、そう簡単にはいきません。
でも簡単じゃないからこそ裁定取引が起こらずに、何十年も非効率さが残っているわけなんです。
そして、英語が通じる大都市は金持ちのビジネスエリート（男性が多い）がたくさんいるので、東京以上に若い女子の売り手しじょうになるんですよね。
エーアイがどれだけ普及しても、英語はできて当たり前で、第二外国語が大事な時代だなと感じます。
メジャーどころだと中国語、スペイン語、ロシア語は人気で無難ですし、アフリカ大陸を攻めたいならフランス語です。
東南アジアだと、ベトナム語、タガログ語、タイ語なんかができると、圧倒的に面白いと思いますね。
僕には無理だけど。
『週刊金融日記 第五百七十六号 第二外国語のすゝめ』
そして、三十代シンママの方、本当におめでとうございます。
この調子で、どんどん進んでいきましょう！
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。